one of the most problematic and also
ignorant confusions that exists in the
socio-political world is the confusion
or blurring of the lines between Jewish
people and Israelis okay
Judaism of course is a religion it's an
ethnicity and it's a culture you could
be ethnically Jewish like for example
I'm Ashkenazi when I do my DNA test it
comes back that I am 100% in fact
Ashkenazi Jewish you could be a
Sephardic Jew you could be a Mizrahi Jew
and you could also convert to a
different religion but ethnically
speaking you would still be Jewish you
can as a separate matter be religiously
Jewish meaning you believe the teachings
of Judaism regardless of whether your
ethnic lis Jewish like for example if
you were adopted by an ethnically and
religiously Jewish family you could
identify as Jewish your religion would
be Jewish but if you did a DNA test
unless you were adopted from a Jewish
family you would not be ethnically
Jewish okay I think we understand that
these designations
none of these designations have anything
to do with being Israeli Israeli is a
nationality there are Israeli Jews there
are Israeli Muslims there are Israeli
Christians this isn't just like a
history lesson or me giving you facts
about this stuff this has a really
serious political impact lots of people
see Jews who are not Israeli and often
have never even been to Israel not that
it matters as equally or more loyal to
Israel than to their home country which
could be the United States it could be
France could be Argentina and this
concept of dual loyalty or split loyalty
is the catalyst for just a ton of
anti-semitism and skepticism of and
discrimination against Jews so it's
really problematic it's worth
understanding what's going on here right
now in 2019 this is especially
problematic because the Prime Minister
of Israel is this extremist outrageous
right winger named Benjamin Netanyahu
and Moe
Jews in the United States are very
liberal meaning that just as we oppose
Donald Trump's policies we oppose the
policies of Benjamin Netanyahu so what
does Donald Trump do he refers to
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu as quote your Prime Minister
in a speech that he gave over the
weekend to American Jews now as it
happens this was a group of the
relatively rare right-wing Jews as I
mentioned most American Jews are quite
progressive so they actually do clap
when Donald Trump mentions mentions
Benjamin Netanyahu but check out what
Donald Trump had to say I stood with
Prime Minister Netanyahu Benjamin
Netanyahu how is the race going by the
way how is it who's gonna win the race
tell me I don't know
Wow it's gonna be close I think it's
gonna be close to good people to good
people but I stood with him you Prime
Minister at the White House to recognize
Israeli sovereignty over the Golan
Heights that's right your Prime Minister
so so listen the story here is not that
american right wing right wing jews or
right wingers in general like benjamin
netanyahu we knew that we've been
talking about that for a long time
the story here is that Donald Trump is
conflating Jews with Israelis and this
is what random people on the Internet do
when I do a segment about the
israeli-palestinian conflict you look at
the comet you look at the comments and
you realize these people don't seem to
know the difference between Jews and
Israelis but this is the president
conflating Jews and Israelis and this is
one of the pillars that's used to foment
anti-semitism and there are a ton of
anti-semitic ideas and attitudes that
stem from this conflation of Jews around
the world with people who are as a
nationality Israeli and it foments this
idea of conflicted loyalty or shared or
split loyalty in some way shape or form
this is what Trump believes there's this
debate as Trump anti-semitic or isn't he
on the one hand he says these horrible
things on the other hand his son-in-law
is Jewish his daughter is Jewish by
conversion his grandkids are Jewish
that's not the right debate okay this is
an example of how it doesn't matter what
Donald Trump thinks and it doesn't
matter what Donald Trump believes what
matters is that this entire idea of
Benjamin Netanyahu as the Prime Minister
of the Jews around the world is the
exact white nationalist thinking that
they use to say Jews should just really
go to Israel and get out of all of the
other countries which of course most
Jews around the world aren't interested
in most Jews are looking to stay in the
countries in which they grew up live or
emigrated to this is their prime
minister this is no more their prime
minister more than Donald Trump is the
president of people in other countries
so the question here becomes this threat
exist
everywhere for Trump when it's Puerto
Ricans from doesn't really see them as
Americans I mean it's an island of
spanish-speaking brown people it just
doesn't really seem like these are
Americans in Puerto Rico Hawaiians well
it's an island of people with
significant in many cases Asian heritage
and it's really far away it's not really
American in the sense that being from
New York or Ohio is American and this is
the exact same idea that Donald Trump is
pushing here it doesn't matter
Trump's opinion of Jews from a point of
view of sort of anti-semitism or
discrimination that's the wrong debate
to be having this entire framing and it
includes Jews it includes Hispanic
people Puerto Ricans Hawaiians there's a
very long list this is serious stuff and
it's mostly ignored as Trump just
misspoke and very often people don't
want to have serious conversations about
it on the one hand it's cartoonish it's
pathetic it's embarrassing but it's
really dangerous stuff because it's
connected to some of the most
reactionary ideologies that are around
and these are not ideologies that have
no support or that are completely
marginal over the last five to seven
years we've seen a significant rise in
the exact type of right-wing nationalism
that is fomented by stuff like Puerto
Ricans are sort of American yeah Jews
are American but really their prime
minister is Benjamin Netanyahu this is
the exact rhetoric that is useful for
the right-wing nationalists to grow
their support in Europe in the United
States in all of the different places
that we've seen it so don't write it off
as Trump Mis speaking this stuff is
important this stuff has an impact and
in the end Jared Kushner being Jewish
doesn't change the fact that when
right-wing nationalists hear this stuff
they hear ideas that they by and large
agree with let me know what you think
make sure to give us a like on Facebook
at facebook.com slash David Pakman show
we'll take a break I want to talk about
the tax return situation coming up next
it's getting very very desperate on the
beat
of the white house today's program was
made possible in part by a simple habit
an app for iOS Android and web browser
that gives you access to more than 2,000
guided meditations you can try it free
for one week by going to simple habit
calm slash Packman simple habit has
meditations made specifically for
anxiety falling asleep overcoming
procrastination getting focused there's
a meditation for almost anything you are
dealing with in life and there is
constantly new scientific research
emerging about the benefits of
meditating regarding your physical
health your mental well-being your
social life your cognitive performance
it's a long list
I personally make meditation part of my
day I've been doing it for a while and
simple habit makes it incredibly easy to
stick to a meditation routine each
guided meditation is just five minutes
long they have meditations specifically
designed for waking up for your daily
commute when you get home from work
every part of your day the massive
variety of different kinds of
meditations that simple habit offers is
what really sets the app apart and they
just won the 2018 Google Play award for
best well-being app you can try it
completely free for a week by going to
simple habit calm / Pakman I think
you'll love it I've put a link right
underneath this video